ah did you guys see this was yesterday
because it is just so adorable this
little cutie right here is Max and pitas
a little boy shy turning 12 weeks old
guys parents fell in love on Dancing
with the Stars of course meanwhile gold
medal gymnast Simone biles it's only
just started going out on dates but has
she already found her perfect 10 ET
online lauren zima found out I've never
had a boyfriend in her life at 20 years
old I feel like you should have gone
through those things and gone on dates
I've been on like one maybe proper date
I got in how did that go need great
thing doing it hey you ready dad not
there but you were baby state earned me
a second date with this guy yeah
probably
Oh what if he's watching right now hey
he's got a good body but that's it I'm
just saying it's I'm just saying he
practiced oh yes Shh you said wait like
John you your mom's gonna do it Simone
and Sasha will do a waltz on Mondays
dancing and contestants will share their
most memorable year this week is is very
special to Simone because it's the first
time that you could actually say
something that she's wanted to say for a
long time why have you not been able to
say it in the past
um there's just no right words or
anything like you can just once you see
the story you'll understand they block a
lot of things out because I am a gymnast
like the emotional side and part of it
but also from my childhood are you guys
gonna cry and our viewers going to cry I
think this so I think everyone's gonna
cry it's like you're like giggling about
it but you know you're gonna get nervous
laugh yes you're nervous oh that's one
Symone does so like when I'm trying to
be serious or I'm like come on Simona
could she giggles in the worst times
she's all giggles but at the end of the
day she works super hard I mean if you
can see what our rehearsal at the
beginning of the week is to learn a
dance to what it looks like at the end
it's night and day
[Music]
you